Marie Antoinette never said if the
people can't afford bread let them eat
cake but the chairman of the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee Sean
Patrick Maloney is campaigning on a
variation of that legendary line as the
Democrats make their final case before
election day
Hudson Valley residents are feeling pain
at the pump and at grocery stores what
have you done and what do you plan to do
to help solve our inflation problem yeah
well I grew up in a family where you
know if the if the gas price went up the
food budget went down so by this time of
the week we'd be eaten Chef Boyardee if
if that budget wasn't going to change
right that's what families have to do
that's what families have to do let them
eat Chef Boyardee
the Democrats are not going to restart
American energy production
Democrats are not going to resolve the
war in Ukraine which is driving up
Energy prices
Democrats aren't going to do anything to
bring prices down
no what the Democrats have to offer
struggling Americans is advice on which
cheap canned pasta soup to buy to feed
your family
a tone-deaf conclusion to a disastrous
campaign by a desperate party who's only
shot at stopping the Electoral tsunami
tonight is to cheat I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Aaron Tuma who
says there's going to be a Blood Moon on
Tuesday even the Moon is voting red
great Point that's absolutely so true I
think a lot of us are fired up I think
our blood is pumping that's true of all
red blooded Americans when you want to
get your blood pumping you got to check
out Echelon Fitness right now text
Knowles to 81 81 81 are you struggling
to reach your fitness goals well as it
turns out having world-class instructors
plus a community of hundreds of
thousands of people who are working
toward the same goal can really help the
guys over at Echelon Fitness have it all
worked out Echelon Fitness is the
affordable way to get workout equipment
a workout community and an instructor's
motivation right in the comfort and
privacy of your own home Echelon
fitness's Connected app provides
thousands of Live And on-demand classes
with great music to keep you moving you
can work at any time day or night
I love my Echelon I have the bike it is
so cool you can go up in the middle of
the night get a great workout in very
engaging very cool instructors you can
even pop in an audiobook or a podcast if
you want they've got the folding
treadmill they've got everything okay
one membership covers a family of five
for a limited time our audience can get
a free bike or rowing machine with a 24
month membership to get your free bike
or rower text Knowles kwles to 81 8181
that is Knolls to 81 81 81 to claim your
free bike or rowing machine text to
Knowles to 81 8181 message and data
rates may apply see terms for details
the Democrats have made their pitch it
has failed it has failed on every issue
according to the polls it has failed in
the swing districts and swing States
according to the polls it's failing even
in places that should be voting Democrat
according to a historical president that
seemed to be toss-ups were leaning red
right now so the only option that they
have is to cheat and they're already
signaling that they're going to do that
the way that they're signaling that is
by claiming that there will be a red
Mirage tonight this according to NBC
News I'm sorry ABC News a red Mirage or
an artificial GOP vote lead will likely
reoccur on Tuesday why reoccur well
because this is the exact same line that
they trotted out in 2020.
they had never trotted this out before
but they tried it out in 2020 because in
2020 unlike pretty much every single
election in American history up until
that point in 2020 we didn't know the
winner on Election night or the day
after election either the day after it
took days and weeks in some cases to
count the votes
and so on Election night the Republicans
looked great and then
they paused the vote in some cases they
just paused Counting for some reason
they put up cardboard in the windows to
stop people from looking at the polling
stations
they found ballots all of a sudden and
you saw the count start to turn for
Democrats
you go to sleep on Election night the
Republicans have won you wake up in the
morning golly
big wave of democrat ballots came in
while you were snoozing looks like the
Democrats won and so they're pitching
this again now the way that they got
away with it in 2020
was they exploited covid and they said
because there's this mild cough that's
come out of China we need to change all
of our election rules to open up the
possibilities for fraud through
mechanisms that include extending
election day to election month extending
mail-in ballots to becoming widespread
phenomenon all sorts of things that even
Barack Obama had previously said open up
the vote to a lot of fraud well now the
Democrats could use it to rig the
election for themselves
that's what they did and so by by
relying on covet using covet as the
justification they were able to rig the
election covet is over though right I
mean Joe Biden has said covet is over
the pandemic is over so then you have to
ask yourself even if you believed this
nonsense in 2020 which I did not but the
Liberals said it with a straight face
and plenty of squishes went along with
it I did not I always thought it was
rigging but
even if you believed it in 2020
how could you possibly believe it now
is this this is just how we conduct
elections now we just now conduct
elections where you get widespread
mail-in ballots there's no such thing as
election day people start voting before
debates even happen when debates even
happen and then it takes days to count
the ballots in super corrupt Democrat
cities where all of a sudden surprise
surprise they're going to find just
enough votes to squeak the Democrats by
does anybody believe that
the longer it takes to count the votes
on Election night or the day after or
the week after
the less you should believe the result
okay it is just as simple as that the
phrase red Mirage is a signal that the
Democrats are going to cheat and they're
trying to tell us with a straight face
that not only is this how elections work
now in these strange times they are
telling us all the way from the White
House Korean sham here White House Press
Secretary
is saying that
this is how voting is supposed to work
it took two weeks to call every state in
modern elections more and more ballots
are being cast in early voting and also
by mail and many states don't start
counting those ballots until after the
ballots after pardon me after the polls
close on November 8th so you heard the
president say this the other night he
has been very clear on this as well we
may not know all but winners of
Elections for a few days it takes time
to count all legitimate ballots in a
legal and orderly manner that's how
that's how this is supposed to work and
it's important for us to all be patient
when while votes are are being counted
this is how it's supposed to work if
this is how it's supposed to work then
how come for pretty much every election
in all of American history since the
founding of our country until two years
ago how come that's not how it worked
how come that's only how it works now
as of as of 2020.
if that's how it's supposed to work
well because we need to make sure that
we tally every single mail-in vote
okay
why do we have so many mail-in votes
well because of covid
because of what covet's over it's been
over for years
well
because
we want to cheat that's why that's why
that's why they're doing it why is it
that Brazil can conduct an election
in one night you know the answer why is
it that France can conduct an election
you know it same night
why is it that the United States until
two years ago could conduction election
you know the results on Election night
but now we can because whatever answer
the Democrats are going to give well
because we've extended the vote and
because we have widespread mail-ins and
well because you know the truck is going
to dump a bunch of ballots in
Philadelphia in the back of a ballot
counting Center whatever the answer is
we should just stop that shouldn't we
don't you think we should we should have
integrity in our elections you know I'm
not the one that rattles on about our
sacred democracy every single day it's
the libs who are doing that well if you
care about our sacred democracy and an
electoral integrity and not being an
election denier that whatever they say
then give us give us a result quickly
the longer it goes on the greater the
opportunity for shenanigans and the less
that people will believe it we know we
know that they're cheating or at least
that they plan to cheat because John
Federman just sued to count ballots that
could have come in after election day
John Federman is in a very tough
position he's running for Senate against
Dr Oz he's the Democrat candidate in
Pennsylvania and he has brain damage and
he's he wasn't even running a great
campaign before he had a stroke and got
brain damage and he tried to hide it
from the public his his health status
and then they had a debate finally with
Dr Oz and fetterman looked terrible and
the polls shifted very strongly in Dr
Oz's favor so at that point the
Pennsylvania state supreme court came
out and said
you can't count fake ballots
that's actually what it said it said
that if you're gonna count the mail-in
ballots they have to be dated and they
have to be dated by election day so you
you're not allowed to count ballots that
are undated because they could have come
in the day after the election or two
days after the election or a week after
the election or however long it's going
to take the Democrats to come up with
enough fake votes so this is really
basic stuff you're not allowed to count
fake ballots says the Supreme Court who
could object to that
only people who are going to try to
cheat namely
John fetterman who's never suing and
saying we absolutely need to count fake
ballots we absolutely need to count
ballots that very likely came in after
the election and of course this is the
case when I look around at the races in
this country
I think Masters versus Kelly that's the
Republican versus the Democrat in the
senate race in Arizona I think that'll
legitimately be close Herschel Walker
the Republican versus Rafael Warnock the
Democrat in Georgia I think that will be
less close but close I look around in
other races
the one though where I'm not feeling
terribly confident for the Republican
is Dr Oz in Pennsylvania not because Oz
is not up in the polls he is up in the
polls
but because Philly is notorious for
corruption
now the Democrat candidate himself is
saying
we're going to sue
to stuff The Ballot Box a tactic that
Democrats have been using for many many
decades
it's awful that could be the death of
our democracy and when we're thinking
about death and your own death you got
to check out epic will right now go to
epicwill.com use promo code at Knowles
what does your family believe in faith
church on Sunday does your family
believe in serving did you vaccinate
your children did you choose not to
vaccinate your children how does your
family Define men and women what kind of
value do they put on life your children
look to you to Define how they view the
world now what if you were not here to
do that for them in the event that you
die and we're all going to die at some
point okay no one here gets out alive
who will ensure that what you hold dear
is upheld by your kids epic will can
help with that
a will lets you determine who will raise
your kids in the event that you die
before you're done raising them this is
your responsibility as a parent it's why
the daily wire has partnered with epic
will take five minutes out of your day
go to epicwill.com to create your
complete will package epic will bundles
your last will living will Healthcare
power of attorney HIPAA release and
durable Financial power of attorney they
look at your entire Legacy your finances
your medical wishes and your
responsibilities as a parent or
caregiver epic will makes early estate
planning super duper easy and affordable
it only costs 119 bucks for a single
person to create a will and when you use
promo code nulls you will save 10 go to
epicworld.com use promo code Knowles
today
why are the Democrats going to cheat
why is everyone talking about election
denial why is everyone including
Republicans including conservatives
including me raising the serious
Prospect of a rigged election or an
illegitimate election
because people don't any longer have
trust in the system
Republicans don't have trust in the
system for all the reasons I just
outlined because the Democrats rig it
and then they brag about rigging it in
Time Magazine and then they sue to rig
it even more like John fetterman why why
do the Democrats believe that the system
is rigged against them
it's it's for a different reason they're
equally convinced of it but it's for a
different reason it's because the
Democrats being Progressive
being fanatically ideologically
Progressive they believe that if
everything were fair and square they
would win every single election this is
a view that is not just coming out of my
own musings this was the view
articulated by a well-known liberal
election lawyer Mark Elias on MSNBC just
yesterday
and I guess my question is around these
lawsuits is it if it's not the point for
them to Prevail but the point to keep
you running around fighting all of their
frivolous litigation what are they so
afraid of if you weren't having to
defend against their attacks on voting
oh I think they're afraid that if
everyone who's able to vote and if we
got an accurate count they'd lose it's
nothing more complicated than that they
know that if every eligible voter was
allowed to cast the ballot and that it
was counted accurately they'd lose that
that has been the whole threat that to
trumpism from the beginning let's forget
let's not forget you know people say
Donald Trump won in 2016. he lost by
three million popular vote that popular
vote uh total uh deficit uh grew in 20
uh in 2020. so they have to find
increasingly creative ways to prevent
the majority will from willing out and
one of the ways you do it is you
suppress the vote but I think that one
of the things they learned is that
that's not enough and they need to
affect the way votes are counted and
elections are certified
so obviously a lot of projection here
since the Democrats are very often the
ones who when there are questions about
how the votes are counted it's in
Democrat cities right it's in
Philadelphia it's in Atlanta it's in all
sorts of play it's in Wisconsin or
Wisconsin dominated by the Democrats so
he's projecting a little bit there but
he's articulating the progressive point
of view which is that
the progressives are obviously right
because they're moving toward progress
the conservatives are obviously evil and
retrograde because they're trying to
impede progress and so they've got very
bad ill will and there are all sorts of
Nefarious people
and therefore because progressivism is
so obviously better for everybody than
if the progressives don't win something
had to have gone awry there had to have
been cheating it has to be rigged
either because the Republicans won't let
the people vote now they're trying to
make this argument but it doesn't really
work because we now have early voting
and you see that voter enthusiasm is
pretty high people are getting out to
vote and this is why you you've heard
left Wingers make the Absurd claim that
just because voter participation is very
high doesn't mean that there's not voter
suppression when that is literally what
it means voter suppression means the
vote goes down voter participation means
the vote goes up and so you can't those
are contradictory things you can't have
both of them at the same time so it's
either because the the voters are not
being allowed to vote but that obviously
isn't happening or because there is
cheating
in the ballot counting but again the
Democrats run the ballot counting and
the places that are being contested
or because the Republicans are spreading
misinformation those are the only three
options
how to explain a republican Victory when
Democrats are supposed to win every
single race and that's why they're
focusing on the misinformation too that
that comes from an idea that the the
marxists in the 20th century really
pushed which is the idea of a false
consciousness feminists also pushed this
perhaps I repeat myself
the idea that people they just don't
understand their own interests they
don't understand their own good they've
been brainwashed by the evil system and
so they can't see what's right for them
and it's not their fault it's really the
system's fault and that's evil and
that's why we've got to take care of the
misinformation but any way you cut it
according to these people
the Republicans cannot legitimately win
which is why I am pointing out now that
no matter who wins and who loses one one
side or the other is not going to accept
the results of the election
and I don't think it's a well both sides
you know are to blame here I think that
Republicans have far more legitimate
reasons to doubt the results of
elections that they lose than the
Democrats do namely that the Democrats
have virtually all of the power in the
United States
especially when it comes to vote
Counting
and in the media and in the bureaucracy
and everywhere
but and in the corporations and in the
social media which spread the
information around before the election
but regardless
it's it's just a fact both sides are
going to doubt it the Democrats are
going to doubt the election because they
don't think that Republicans are
legitimate participants in our sacred
democracy Joe Biden said half the
country is fascist terrorist an
existential threat to our democracy so
they don't think that we have any right
to win elections they don't think we
have any right to participate in
elections really and they say that and
it's not just the Fringe lunatics it's
the president of the United States who
says that that's why they won't accept
it the Republicans will be skeptical of
intellectual laws one because all the
polls are showing we're supposed to
absolutely crush it tonight but two
because the Democrats rig elections and
brag about rigging the elections and
they publish long-time magazine articles
about how they recollection so that
would be I think
for a more legitimate reason than the
Democrats have but either way I'm just
making it the descriptive statement
that no matter how you cut it one side
is going to deny the election the other
one is going to accept the election or
you know it'll be one side or
the other
now for the crime of making this
observation Hassan the God he's the
young guy from The Young Turks I think
he's chunk euger's uh nephew
I did a show with him once it was on one
of the Fox shows with him one time uh he
said that I'm I'm Desiring violence
I pointed out
the Republican view on this which is
that the Democrats rigged the elections
and I said the longer it takes to tally
the votes the less you should believe
the result he
Hassan says pretty wild that the
Republican party is collectively gearing
up Their audience to lose their minds
after they did everything to make sure
Mal and ballot results come in later
than same-day votes I don't even think
Dems will win but it's certain that they
want violence
where
in what insane world could you possibly
interpret what I said
as calling for violence
so the longer it takes to tally the
votes the less you should believe the
result where it show me the violence
take me out of it for a second
where have you ever seen ever the
Republicans committing violence over an
election
well we saw it on January 6th when the
Republicans murdered all those police
officers and no then none of that
happened none of that happened the only
person who was killed in political
violence on January 6th was a trump
supporter killed by a trigger-happy cop
okay
now where else have we seen political
violence have we seen any political
violence in recent years
oh yeah when that lib tried to murder
Justice Kavanaugh and oh yeah yesterday
when I lived through a beer can in Ted
Cruz's head and oh yeah when the
Democrats burned the country down for
like eight months during the BLM and
antifa riots killing dozens of people
and burning businesses and setting
courthouses on fire yeah I guess we saw
it then didn't we
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah on
setting church is on fire on and on and
on
statistically 100 of political violence
in the U.S comes from the Democrats
statistically zero percent of it ever
comes from the Republicans
but
the Democrats believe that they're
justified in political violence because
they're fighting the evil fascist nazi
racist threat to our democracy namely
every Republican in the country
and they believe that Republicans are
are illegitimate citizens and they have
no right to do anything
they believe that the very the continued
existence of Republicans is inflicting
violence in the country that is what the
president has said
so it's it is absurd but my observation
Remains the Same the loser is going to
deny the election
that's just a fact
and and there could be violence Hassan
is right in that there could be violence
it will not come from the right
we don't have enough power for it we
don't have the inclination for it we do
have a view of the world that includes
objective morality we just don't want to
do it for all the rights talk of well
we've got our guns we got our Second
Amendment the right is not interested in
political violence the left is the left
exercises political violence constantly
and if they lose you'll probably see
more of it
and you are already seeing him a little
bit because my friend Ted Cruz actually
was he was pretty sprightly up there he
was on a campaign vehicle going through
the streets some guy wasn't even a beer
can he threw it was a white claw cam
which is very funny I love white claws
but it's kind of a girly drink to throw
at somebody uh they went
Senator Cruz was able to fend off the
can I think the guy got arrested and
then and then Ted tweeted out and said
uh thank goodness that guy has a noodle
for an arm because it didn't hurt too
bad but you were already seeing the
violence and it ain't coming from the
right
speaking of political violence coming
from the left there has been a very
underreported phenomenon
of left-wingers vandalizing burning
spring graffiti on pro-life pregnancy
centers the libs have not answered for
this it's awful I mean that's an attack
on some of the most vulnerable women and
poor little babies that you could
possibly imagine and these absolute
demons are running around perpetrating
these crimes so finally a reporter asked
White House Press Secretary Karine
Jean-Pierre about it here's her answer
in the meantime like pro-life pregnancy
centers are being attacked it is just it
that is just not something that uh that
I'm going to comment from here about
what the former president said uh it is
you know uh just not going to get any
further again I'm just not going to get
any further
I'm just not going to comment about that
because I want it to keep happening
that's what they're saying it's the same
answer that Corrine Jean-Pierre gave
when you had those left-wing protesters
illegally demonstrating outside of the
private homes of Supreme Court Justices
it's a violation of federal law the
federal government was not enforcing the
law why because they wanted it to keep
happening the White House sort of
cheekily said well you know we don't
have an opinion on where people protest
people going to protest wherever they
want it's a nice house you got there
Brett Kavanaugh it's nice kids you got
up there sure would be a shame if
something happened to them it's the same
thing here hey what do you guys think
about the Liberals firebombing the
pro-life pregnancy centers
I don't have any comment on it
but I would like to tell all of the
arsonists and the terrorists that if you
keep it up
we're just not we're just not going to
see it See No Evil Hear No Evil
say no evil is the White House Press
Secretary
there is an undercurrent of a threat
coming from the liberal establishment
from the Democrats even from the White
House
you heard Ron Clane yesterday on the
show white house chief of staff so he's
the man presumably was running the
country while Joe Biden goes and Licks
Ice Cream and smells people's hair and
sort of wanders about the East Wing this
is a guy with a ton of power in
Washington and he said you know
we're giving you one final warning don't
elect Republicans this is one final
warning
one final warning who am I talking to
Tony Soprano over here is this a
Shakedown yeah one final warning well
when one final warning is coming from
your you know neighbor down the street
old Widow McGillicuddy who comes up and
says I'm Justin warning you it'd be very
bad if you voted for this person
tomorrow then you can take that in the
spirit of advice from somebody when the
guy who runs the government tells you
here's a warning don't do this you're
gonna have a choice tomorrow
don't don't pick the r option pick the D
or what
yeah or you know
you're not gonna like it f around and
find out that's basically what they're
saying
there is an undercurrent of threat
to all of this
and and and we know that the extents
that they are willing to go to
have no limit I mean for goodness sakes
they're mutilating little kids
right they kill babies in the womb they
chop off the genitals of kids they'll do
anything they they they will come after
you I promise you that there's a
transgender activist who's gone viral
gosh that that could just be a daily
lead-in to any segment there's a
transgender activist who's gone viral
spreading a bunch of child abuse
propaganda so this fellow who is dressed
up like a like a cross between Pagliacci
and Baphomet you know is just very
creepy very occult kind of Look to Him
uh he is insisting
that the libs are not transiting the
kids
no surgical intervention happening to
transgender children to change their sex
this is simply not happening here are
the actual facts facts medical
professionals are not giving puberty
blockers to children who have not
reached puberty in fact puberty blockers
are fully reversible facts hormone
treatments don't generally begin until
after 16 years of age facts sex
reassignment surgery is considered at 18
based on making certain criteria facts
gender affirming care is life-saving
care share this post to spread facts
so only one of those things that he said
is a fact
that would be the first part where he
said fact
we're not giving puberty blockers to
people who haven't reached puberty
right that yeah it wouldn't make sense
to give puberty blockers to a
two-year-old because uh it wouldn't it
wouldn't do anything I mean it would
probably mess up their biochemistry but
there would be no puberty to block so
you wouldn't give them a puberty Blocker
of course you only give it to kids who
are on the brink of puberty but that
that's what we're saying you're doing
and that's what you're admitting that
you're doing so there you have it
then he makes a bunch of other claims
that are not true he says they're
reversible in many cases they're not and
we've interviewed people who explain how
they're not and who have the scars to
prove it uh there's no study that shows
that they're reversible it's just
nonsense there's there's no persuasive
study that shows that they're reversible
uh same thing about the gender
mutilations and the hormone therapy and
the going under the knife and everything
you notice he says that's generally done
when you're 18. that's supposed to
happen when you're 18. yeah sure right
maybe that's the rule but we've got
audio from Libs of tick tock of
hospitals admitting that they perform
these surgeries on very young children
including 13 year olds maybe younger so
that's all nonsense but let's just take
him at his word
let's take him in his word and say we're
not transcending the libs are not
transiting the kids it's not happening
Republicans are tilting at windmills
this is all Much Ado About Nothing
okay then let's ban it
good it's not happening you're not
transiting the kids we're just tin foil
hat lunatic conspiracy theorists we're
making up a bunch of not okay good then
let's just ban it because it's not
happening
so you don't need to worry about it
because the ban it's not going to do
anything at all
let's it'll make us feel better just
appease those crazy right-wingers and
then since you guys aren't transiting
the kids there's no big deal right
right
no of course they would never go for
that they refuse to go for that
because it is happening
it was the same argument that they made
about the wall
is it walls
we can't build a wall on the southern
border because because walls are
ineffective
walls don't work
you know remember Nancy Pelosi
who I think she probably wishes she had
a bigger wall now but who has security
at her house all of the libs who have
lots of security and lots of big walls
they say walls don't work
okay
if walls don't work
just humor Us
it's not that expensive to build the
wall costs a fraction of a fraction of
an iota of a fraction of the kind of
money that the libs want to spend on a
bunch of nonsense so okay just let us
build it don't worry it doesn't work
so it's not a big deal and then what did
they say they said well the walls don't
work and they're very cruel
if it doesn't work
then how is it cruel it can't be cruel
because it doesn't do anything to be
cruel you have to have some effect if
it's cruel then I guess it works
let me back away from it it's the same
thing with abortion they say no
abortions happen in the third trimester
they don't really even happen in the
second trimester so it's the first
trimester that's when abortions happen
okay late term abortion it's a
Republican
fear-mongering Boogeyman oh okay then
let's ban it would you be willing to ban
it you said it doesn't happen
well well whoa whoa whoa there I mean
okay there you you're giving up the game
obviously it does happen and you're just
lying
you're just lying about it and we called
your bluff
and now we know and you're going to keep
up the charade and you're going to keep
a straight face and you're gonna say
we're not rigging the vote
no I'm just filing a lawsuit to count
ballots that were cast after election
day but we're not rigging it what are
you talking about you're crazy
okay
if you're not rigging the boat the vote
then even putting aside widespread
mail-ins and early voting and all the
rest let's at least agree you don't
count the ballots that aren't postmarked
by election day right
let's we can at least agree on that
because you're not rigging it so it's
not a problem there aren't any of those
votes coming in oh oh wait you're going
to sue me in court now because you want
to count those ballots okay because
you're obviously
obviously rigging it
you see this kind of argument all the
time with the transgender stuff speaking
of sexual confusion
huge news story I'm meant to mention
this a few days ago
really big stuff though
headline
a pair of international pageant winners
are showing love knows no boundaries
Miss Argentina 2020 Mariana Varela
and Miss Puerto Rico 2020 Fabiola
Valentin said they got married last
month that's great news for these
beautiful young women I'm so glad they
got married but if you look at the
picture I don't see their husbands
anywhere
and that's kind of weird these these two
they both got I guess they're very good
friends they got married on the same day
I guess well great but where are the
husbands
I don't
wait a second
hold on a minute here oh no they're
they're saying they got married to each
other but that's not possible because
they're girls they're both girls and two
girls can't get married to each other
because marriage intrinsically
has to do with sexual difference and
complementarity
and everyone knows that that's true and
some people want to be willfully
ignorant of that but we all know that
that's true if marriage has any meaning
at all it has to have something to do
with sexual difference and marriage in
fact is the Perpetual Union of one man
and one woman for the sake of the
generation and education of children so
just a little plug here our pal Matt
Walsh went on The Joe Rogan show a few
days ago and he defended marriage and
Joe seemed really shocked by this and
kept pushing back and it was just a
wonderful discussion uh you know
everyone's got a Monday Morning
Quarterback and say Matt should have
said this or he should have said that or
he should but whatever I think Matt did
a great job and it's I think it's really
important to have a prominent voice out
in public on the biggest podcast of
America Joe Rogan having that
conversation big props to Joe Rogan for
even opening it up I I know a lot of
squishy Republicans who wouldn't even
talk about the marriage issue I know a
lot of self-style conservatives who
wouldn't be willing to have an actual
debate about what marriage is the debate
that never happened by the way before
The Supreme Court redefined it so really
good stuff it's definitely worth
checking out tonight is a special night
at the daily wire we are having an event
called daily wire election night 2022.
coverage will start at 3 P.M Central and
run until 11 pm at 6 PM I will get
together with Ben Matt Drew the god king
Jeremy boring lowercase G Candace and
all the rest of the gang to celebrate
the moments as they happen we will give
you live updates from the morning wire
team plus any pertinent social media
meltdowns from the night maybe AOC comes
on Instagram I don't know we'll bring it
to you if that were not enough to get
the popcorn popping we will also be
joined by some very special guests get
the election news that you need to know
in real time with expert commentary and
a healthy dose of humor come celebrate
the incoming Red Wave with us tonight
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member yet go to dailywire.com Knowles
to join today
there was a big announcement last night
I got a text from Jeremy says turn on
the Trump rally
so why
it's Trump there's rumors he might
announce that he's running for president
turn on the Trump rally it's a rally in
Ohio for JD Vance very important race as
goes Ohio so goes the nation
Trump's out there campaigning until the
last minute
but he was teasing all night you heard
the media
showing up is he going to announce that
he's running in 2024
and I thought instantly no he's not
a lot of people thought he would
Trump supporters thought he would a lot
of people who hate Trump thought that he
would
I did not think that he would it doesn't
look good enough it's not enough about
him the Optics weren't great some people
said well his family's there the whole
family was not there his wife I don't
think was there Baron I don't think was
there so it just I never bought it I
suspected from the beginning that it was
a media troll so that Trump could get
all the news networks to turn on the
cameras for his rally and then he would
just read the Litany of candidates that
he was endorsing in a race and then
he made this announcement I would say in
the strongest way it's a country-saving
election
specifically including
the election of all the people that I'm
going to name
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
we want nothing to detract from the
importance of tomorrow
they want nothing to detract from the
importance of Tomorrow Trump and the
whole team so is a troll it was a troll
from the beginning which is really great
stuff absolutely adore it
uh and then Trump comes out and he says
but
that announcement that you're waiting
for I am going to make it next Tuesday
so Trump is going to run
almost certainly
and I don't know am I the last
conservative pundit in America who
doesn't hate Trump
Michael that maybe that's too strong am
I the last conservative pundit in
America who wouldn't be upset if Trump
runs again
I like Trump
Trump was the greatest conservative
president in my lifetime Trump posed a
legitimate I think a real serious threat
to the system from the system of
absolutely
desiccated corrupt decadent liberal
establishment nonsense
he posed a threat in a way that no
Republican in my lifetime has and are
there other potentially good candidates
on the right sure and they'll duke it
out in a primary process but I'm just
not willing to throw Trump aside the man
is still very energetic the man is
unique in American politics he is a
world historic figure he is a sort of
hegelian character okay it is all about
him some people say well why is Trump
making it all about him one he didn't
make it all about him last night he
actually did wait until after the
election and endorsed his candidates but
two
it is all about him he is an American
original one of a kind and so I'm not
willing to say oh Trump
oh he's too old oh he's too deep his
tweets are too mean oh whatever no I
like him I still like the guy
I will not be upset if he runs I hope
that whatever primary campaign takes
place does not
destroy other strong good Republicans
there's a lot of them out there
everyone's talking about Ron DeSantis
but there's others as well I hope that
it's a good strong robust primary we get
the best candidate but I don't know the
arguments against Trump to me fall flat
well Trump is so bruised and bloodied
right you don't think they're going to
do that to whoever the nominee is
in fact in some ways they've they've
thrown the kitchen sinkatron but hasn't
stuck so hey that's actually a Mark I
think in his favor
well Trump is too old yeah okay we won
every every conservative's last favorite
Republican president was the oldest
president in American history so I don't
think that and now we just elect old
people so okay that's the way it goes uh
he got Roe v Wade overruled he built a
fair portion of the wall he had the best
foreign policy ever in my lifetime uh he
uh brought peace to the Middle East for
goodness sakes
he got tough on trade he reordered
Republicans economic priorities into a
much more sane sort of way he I don't
know I just I'm not saying he's the best
candidate necessarily for 2024. I
haven't really looked at the 2024 race
all that closely yet because we're
focused on the midterms but
I'm not willing to throw the guy out I
just really like him I still like the
guy okay all right and that's that I
make no apologies for it
though he was rushing things a little
bit last night
he's right you know it's early it's 2022
why are we talking about 2024. speaking
of rushing things
Mariah Carey
Mariah Carey
she just just around Halloween
Mariah Carey released
the most terrifying thing I saw all
Halloween
[Music]
it's Mariah Carey on a bicycle in a
pumpkin patch with a witch hat on oh
[Music]
it's time and here it is
Christmas Mariah Carey
[Music]
on a reindeer playing that awful song
oh it's so awful it's so awful
it's not time it says it's time it's not
time
there should be no Christmas music
Before Christmas Day
there should be no Christmas music
before Advent
there should certainly be no Christmas
music before Thanksgiving guys come on
put everything in its proper place all
right
there's a time for every season under
heaven
and this is something that we we just
don't have a really good sense of
anymore we just rush everything when
we're in the Eternal present we're all
addicted to social media everything's
had just got to happen as fast as
possible we don't have the virtue of
patience and this is going to matter a
lot
what do you think about 2024 because
everyone right now is saying well is it
Trump or DeSantis that's it right
at this time in the 2016 cycle who were
the leading candidates
they were the first people to drop out
at this time in the 2012 cycle who were
the leading candidates Mitch Daniels and
Bobby Jindal Haley Barber
none of whom made it even close to the
presidency so we've got time
maybe it'll be Trump maybe it'll be Ron
DeSantis maybe it'll be someone that
you're not even thinking of right now
now speaking of women like Mariah Carey
harming the culture
Kathy Griffin baby this is some of the
greatest news it's sort of related to
the election
it's definitely giving us a lot of Joy
Elon Musk has uh suspended Kathy Griffin
from Twitter permanently
he's done it because Kathy Riven
impersonated him a lot of people have
been impersonating Elon Musk if they
have a blue check mark they'll change
their name to Elon Musk put his picture
in pretend to be him so she did that now
she's permanently banned I love it
and the libs are dunking right they're
saying well yeah so much for free speech
this is Elon is showing us the way I
published my book last year
with a contrarian take on Free Speech
the whole conservative movement was
saying we need absolute Free Speech all
the time and no guard rails and no
standards and no taboos and I said no no
that's not how Free Speech actually
works the left understands Free Speech a
lot better than we do
it's good to censor certain things it's
good to censor obscenity at least it's
good to censor all sorts of things could
have standards it's good to have a
Common Language you have to have that
that's what politics is and I think that
view has prevailed I think that
the book became a number one National
bestseller and I'm very happy about all
of that I think people are recognizing
The Way Forward is not this
do whatever you want hands in the air
I'm not going to govern I'm not going to
wield power kind of
frivolous libertarianism The Way Forward
is
when conservatives are given power when
we earn power when the people elect us
we have not just the right but the
responsibility to wield that power for
the good more good less bad the libs
wield power for more bad and less good
we need to weld it for more good less
bad certainly very good to kick Kathy
Griffin off Twitter for her fraud
really they could kick her off Twitter
for her terrible comedy but I think it's
also fair to kick her off for committing
fraud
now speaking of insane women
Anne Hathaway just went on The View
again this is in the final days of the
campaign
to Double Down triple down quadruple
down on the one issue that Democrats
have really focused on this campaign the
quote unquote right to abortion The
Devil Wears product did turn 16 this
summer yes the time flies boy so you
wrote this on Instagram quote I am
struck by the fact that the young female
characters in this movie built their
lives and careers in a country then
honored their right to have Choice over
their own reproductive Health see you in
the fight so why did you write that why
was it important to you for to you to
write something like that because we're
in the fight yeah we're in the fight
every day we're in the fight every
minute and you mentioned the Devil Wears
Prada turning sweet 16 yeah some 16 year
old's life has been irrevocably changed
yeah because of the current overturning
of Roe v Wade and in this character I
played a young woman who was starting
out her career
and when you are a young woman starting
out your career your reproductive
Destiny matters a great deal of course
my own personal experience with abortion
and I don't think we talk about this
enough abortion can be another word for
mercy
so here she seems to be insinuating that
she's killed one or more of her children
[Music]
out of Mercy
for the children so it could be you know
I mean what what often happens is that
when people find out that their child
has some kind of disorder maybe they're
down syndrome maybe they've got some
kind of problem uh
people today will often just kill their
children and say well we're going to try
again this is why you hear out of
Iceland they say we've eradicated Down
syndrome there's no cure for Down
syndrome so it just means that people
are killing their Down syndrome babies I
don't know exactly what Anne Hathaway
means by this she's using all sorts of
euphemisms but she's saying my own
abortion experience is that abortion can
be an act of mercy and so it's really
weird the fact that she's using
euphemisms I think just proves to you
right there that the she recognizes that
what she's talking about is evil and
will rub people the wrong way and will
be offensive because of how awful it
actually is and the Democrats are using
all sorts of euphemisms now and they're
doing absolutely everything they can to
get around to to to kind of leap over uh
reality the the reality of their of
their policies the reality of their
agenda and the real perception of what
they want from the people and so if the
people aren't going to vote for them
they're going to they're gonna try to
get around that too I hope they do not
succeed in that but it will be a very
interesting night the first part that
will be interesting are the polls
in those tight races who's going to win
who's going to win New York's 17th
congressional district who's going to
win in Georgia who's going to win in
Arizona but then there's going to be an
entirely
distinct and frankly more interesting
fight that happens which is that if the
races really are close you're going to
see the battle for uh whether or not the
Democrats can properly rig it
to uh let's say let's say Oz is only up
by one or two points can they make up
those ballots in the middle of the night
with undated fraudulent ballots to send
John fetterman
to Washington D.C you know the rest of
the show continues now
we got a great pollster on to tell us
what to look for tonight if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]